the world is moving faster every day
people are constantly online they use
smartphones and social networks to
communicate in real time people eat on
the go what matters most is speed
Lamont's potthast wanted to slow things
down a bit he designed a decelerator
helmet the helmet makes things appear
slower than they are the front of the
helmet has a screen and camera the
camera sends videos of the outside world
to a computer inside the computer slows
down the video then sends the footage to
video screen glasses for the person
wearing the helmet everything outside
moves in slow motion as an excited with
the helmet lets you slow things done the
idea came from a course at the
University of Arts in Bremen which aimed
at developing interactive ways of
dealing with our fast-paced society lots
of commonly laurens potthast wants to
help people understand time differently
own damn can I ok I'll wave now and make
some interesting movements like jumping
life 15 I don't know how you're gonna
feel when you see that you can tell me
what it feels like seeing easy stuffs
one food I've even wait here I am yeah
that's a really weird feeling because
it's so slow you turn around in circles
and somehow you don't it's a little
confusing but it's really cool I were in
2012 pot has posted a video online to
explain his invention it's got more than
300,000 hits technology blogs and print
magazines from around the world
contacted potthast to learn more
huzzle does his effort in the beginning
I got a lot of questions from websites
later newspapers started contacting me
for their reports and interviews then I
was invited to a number of media
festivals and trade shows methyl the
chops nestled in the end I flew to New
York and won a big prize captain Foong
pies come on people are fascinated by
the idea of time control the most
popular film known for manipulating time
is the matrix trilogy computer games
like Max Payne 3 also use slow motion
Laurens potthast wanted to bring that
feeling to reality it took the blame and
design student for months to build his
decelerator helmet the ethnics ferment
important report the first experiments
and prototypes with the helmet I just
walked around with a laptop strapped to
a bike helmet on the hood off generally
that worked good function yet I wake up
but then I thought it would be better if
i hit the most vital parts Pashtun
village terminus 10 [ __ ] a metal
sphere protects against rain and curious
stares potthast found and bought it
online his helmet isn't something you
can wear all day you shouldn't walk
around when you have it on the person
wearing it loses all orientation not all
people in the outside world like the
concept of a decelerated world one time
because sometimes I feel like too much
is happening at once but maybe other
people need things to move fast
sometimes I need things to happen all
the time too deceleration is a really
subjective concept just concept this the
23 year old still receives many
questions about his deceleration helmet
right now he's busy working on his
master's thesis lowlands podcasts life
hasn't slowed down it's sped up
shift says the world can pass you by in
the wink of an eye